i wake up every morning in a bed that's
too small driving my daughter to a
school that's too expensive and then i
go to work to a job for which i get paid
too little but on pretzel day
well i like pretzel
day because they're acting all tough and
everything but what they were rapping
about was cupcakes the chronicles of
narnia uh who invented cupcakes right i
want to kill hey hey hey phyllis what
are you doing i'm just saying hi to bob
no i think you're cutting in line well
settle down scott no i'm not going to
settle down no way uh-uh get in the back
please
[Music]
thank you
that's right
what a pair of mary's this is pretzel
day
oh come on it's not real stanley don't
have a heart no no no no no you will not
die daily stanley you will not die
stanley stanley barack is president
you are black certainly i'm gonna give
him mouth-to-bottom no no no don't give
him out the mouth for this you're gonna
swallow his tongue open your mouth
michael swan don't swallow him
i'm fine leave me alone
i
am a victim of a hate crime
stanley knows what i'm talking about
that's not what a hate crime is well i
hated it a lot okay i look at those
wrinkles blacks do crack
not crack the drug all right since i am
the boss i will drive as well who wants
shotgun you can't be serious you ran a
woman over this morning everyone inside
the car was fine stanley
hold up hold up hold up hold on no no no
no no time to stop being polite and get
real
stan lee you having an affair
that is ridiculous of course not why
would you think that so it's not true
okay well
oh
those interns they told me they saw you
at the club
and they all said it was you it's
clearly just
racial profiling gossip the little damn
told her was a stupid idea to go up in
this club so stupid it's just that
terry's been traveling a lot i love you
i know it's been lonely oh i bet i hey
cynthia's been keeping me company
she was my nurse
when i was in rehabilitation we used to
go on these long walks on the treadmill
i didn't
wait wait wait
hold it is true yeah but michael i'm
going to go break it off that's where
i'm headed right now oh my god wait a
second do people often say they're going
on sales calls and then go someplace
else because that's not cool i just need
you to promise not to say a word about
this to anyone
michael please i'm not saying
damn i'm counting on you michael okay
you can count on me
i've got a golden ticket idea why don't
you skip on up to the roof and jump off
that is not constructive
like everybody's attention
christmas is cancelled you can't cancel
a holiday give it up stanley and you
will lose new year's what does that mean
jim take new year's away from stanley
michael i am the only one here who has a
legitimate
disability
although i'm sure stanley has had his
fair share of obstacles
i'm not disabled and neither are you
okay
what does this look like to you stanley
mailboxes etc shut
it okay
why is she trying to take stanley from
us i think it's because of my sales
record that could not possibly be it
you cannot take the hilarious black guy
from the office
stanley is part of what makes this
branch so extraordinary the bluesy
wisdom the sassy remarks
the crossword puzzles
this smile
those big watery red eyes
i don't know how george bush did it when
colin powell left
and if utica thinks that they are going
to poach stan lee they have another
thing coming
how can i get you to stay money
yeah
we all want money
but there is none on the budget so
tell me why you're really leaving money
no money more problems stanley you of
all people should know that let me ask
you this
if i were money
i like this maybe a whole theme like a
wrap a wrap rhyme urban thing an urban
yeah stanley you want to help us out
with that
stanley earth is stanley not me yes you
come on stanley put your little game
down and and join the group no
stanley we're having a little bit
down a brainstorm session
good this is good i'm going to grab a
glass of water
stanley hudson
you are fired
are you serious
i am serious we are all serious
you're fired like a heart attack you're
firing me
over three words
have you lost your mind
do you think i'm gonna let you do this
to me hmm i've watched you screw up this
office for 10 years and i'm filing a
lawsuit and i'm going to tell them about
every stupid thing you've ever done up
in this office all right okay you know
what
now you know how i feel
this was a fake firing
lesson learned good work everybody very
nice
so i'm not fired
that's it
and uh
do you have anything to say to me oh yes
i do
you are out of your damn little
pea-sized mind what is wrong with you do
you have any sense at all okay do you
have any idea how to run an office every
day you do something stupider than you
did the day before and i think there's
no possible way he can top that but what
do you do you find a way damn it to top
it you are a professional idiot hey stop
it
okay everybody out who yeah everybody
except stanley
let's go i can't find my glasses okay
you know what why don't you take my hand
and leave them and let's get
it's michael versus stanley and it is
the clash of the titans in one corner
you have michael and he is mad and then
in the other corner you have stanley and
he's matt
so that's about it
i don't understand why you keep picking
on me no for the love of god just
do and i don't know why so
please help me understand fine
here it is
you are a person i do not respect
the things you say your actions your
methods and style everything you would
do i would do it the opposite way
well stanley
maybe you are feeling that you don't
respect me because you don't know me
very well
michael i've known you a very long time
and the more i've gotten to know you the
less i've come to respect you
any other theories
all right you don't respect me
i accept that
but listen to me
you can't talk to me that way in this
office you just can't i am your boss
can't allow it
there enough
hey what up cynthia
just hang on a second cynthia
well it turns out that terry was already
suspicious because she had caught
stanley and cynthia a few months ago
so stanley promised
that he would stop and he did end of
story well
not exactly
uh cynthia kept calling him she would
not stop calling him and she was in love
with them oh and get this cynthia also
married so
you